qu'est ce qu'on va faire aujourd'hui à
part boire du café on va mettre les
vampires à poil en plein soleil mon pote
et wet où il a été repéré aide bienvenue
sur akiba's trip oendan andreessen undd
reste entre scènes c'est moche les
bilingues ou les oreilles qui saignent
actuellement je vais pas vous spoiler
mais c'est un jeu très très bien foutu
dans lequel on va devoir défoncer une
meute de vampires vilain qui veulent
nuire à tokyo on va s'appeler déshabille
à tort voilà pour faire un nom un peu
flippant juste tu prends un verre mais
tu rajoutes tort à la fin on est cet
homme qu'on put on y va akihabara à cuba
pour faire court cette ville en a vu à
vue de tous l'histoire a dit oui le
japon a traversé des époques difficiles
et aujourd'hui c'est une époque de plus
il ya des bons pères qui veulent tuer
des gens vont le déshabiller à tort se
réveille et à son chef le dérangeait pas
c'est déjà le matin bien mais amiens on
dirait que tu t'es finalement réveillé
oh mon dieu
le méchant trop stylé au costard rose et
à la coupe un peu effarouchés tu as
passé l'examen de compatibilité et tu es
maintenant play commencer sa nouvelle
vie en tant que sa sister rien de
religieux dans tout ça je suis attaché à
une table mois legrand des habits à tort
qu'ils habillent les gens dans la rue
j'étais en train de faire l'entretien ne
bouge pour devenir journaliste et c'est
parti en steak au reste calme a pas
comme mes cheveux ils sont déchaînés qui
nous a vendu ton âme tout naissance à
nous master zenia tard il y à un intrus
dans le building jeu haut
[Musique]
mais pousse banquiers tels qu'ils
étaient l'action parra plus divin et sa
beauté divine suis moi on s'en va d'ici
ok je te suis fait attraper les voilà ça
japonais ça voulait vraiment dire
rattraper les fils de [ __ ] on va se
battre au plus tard au moment du but a
eu droit peut-être mon gars tu sais pas
qui je suis mais que j'ai fait un nom du
karaté j'ai fait des katas mon gars et
je sais parfaitement comment te retirer
ton pantalon
hop là voilà énorme patate douanes bonne
mon gars c'est nous ok c'était très bien
tu es plus fort que je ne l'imaginais
bah oui oui bah oui on ce combat auto
ados comme dans les films comme
d'angelina et brad pitt dans ces acteurs
spa long du film on s'en fou comment
osez vous oh non il a tapé mon ami on
s'est interposé entre le coût et la
femme y at il une meilleure technique
pour séduire une femme non tu m'a
protégé ouais bon voilà c'est pas fait
exprès ne laissez pas s'échapper
ok j'y vais reste bien derrière moi je
te suis sam paille c'est vraiment notre
samba et la map share je crois qu'on les
a sommés tuer blesser c'est quand tu m'a
protégé n'est ce pas on aurait dit que
tu contrôler la chose mais en fait pas
du tout été une énorme merde c'est la
grosse [ __ ] bon je crois qu'on n'a pas
d'autre choix
je vais partager un peu de bon sens avec
toi db attendant qu'un ticket groupe
sanguin groupe sanguin t ou plus a + b b
- tentent autant ce n'est pas compatible
tu va me tuer en fait ça va te sauver
mais pendant quelques jours tu va
beaucoup souffrir
bon écoute tu sais quand je regarde tes
beaux yeux avec ce sens comme ça qu'on
élève
j'ai l'impression que ton père est un
voleur et qu'il a volé toutes les
étoiles du ciel pour te mettre dans les
yeux pour tous les mettre dans les yeux
pardon parce que j'ai âge et j'ai arrêté
l'école en 6e si tu veux saisir cette
chance il te plait bois mon sens
as tu dois plus on est sur du a+ à a
tenu bon bien sûr va comme ça on aurait
pu tomber par exemple sur ça et ouais
mon gâteau ont été déçus on dirait que
ça a pris d'assaut dès qu'on parle de
pêche quoi adapté je suis un chasseur et
mon devoir est de chasser ces monstres
les saints sisters ta vie n'est plus en
danger des habits à tort mais tu es
toujours faible et tu es très très
vulnérable au soleil
ok ben amos et ailleurs qui a la playa
tu vois ce que je veux dire on veut pas
cramé maintenant place aux lilas mais
attends mais eduardo twilight qui fait
ça et les bords homme mon dieu on est
totalement am et attend maintenant mais
beck vous soucier de ma dernière vidéo
au japon il y avait mon frère qui était
là et moi je me filmer devant ce ces
gars-là c'est de là dedans quand
s'affrontent à tekken et que j'ai battu
floraux chars bien sûr éclairage et men
origins et le section pourront acheter
jackie chan ici présents je suis content
je passe trop sexy objections n'importe
quoi je confonds tout jacques chagnon
l'acheter dans une petite rue là bas à
droite mais le sex-shop là où il ya tous
les trucs hyper glauque cesser ce
bâtiment là juste là mec t'as ils ont
vraiment reproduit à cabara kouao je
suis habité par ce jeu pour aller à
l'aller on a un objectif à atteindre
on a des vampires [ __ ] à poil d'ours
pas tout mais bon comment tu te sens
tout va bien bien les mecs ils nous ont
attaqué hier n'abandonneront pas si
facilement
merde ils sont là quoi déjà tabet c'est
elle on l'a retrouvé [ __ ] merde il n'a
pas pu envoyer des filles
j'ai aimé c'est vrai la sexologue
hasarde pas à la malbouffe the coup
c'est beau c'est une blague de bol ça va
bientôt à elle c'est parti on va le
défoncer make up là haut il a fait des
scribouillards tiens tiens tiens tiens
au les coûts beaucoup lu mais les saints
sisters honte accord très résistant donc
les blessures physiques ne suffiront pas
à les vaincre
je vais te montrer ici pour aller battre
premièrement choisi un revêtement
spécifique par exemple son bandana roues
alors la baisse on attaque or le corps
ou alors le pantalon en attaquant le
pantalon au képi sondage là et voilà ça
passe à côté pour portal o ok donc le
but ça va être d'abîmer les les
vêtements des mecs et ensuite quand ils
seront suffisamment avignon pour aller
retirer genre là du coup mais non mais
laisse pas trop tirer ton pote à quoi tu
veux pas je comprends pas moi un mec de
rue pour me dire mon pantalon j'accepte
gervasi de toi bien frère ben ouais là
c'est bon la maman alors ok la veste et
hop là alors on est vu comme un ver de
terre
oh non il son corps s'est dissous à la
la attends je sens le truc venir où
généralement les bosses ce sera des
meufs ultra sexy c'est comme par hasard
et hop là optique elles sont bleues on
est sur du bleu c'est pas mal très bon
choix allait bien là revient à bien
cette petite veste la tuque le bandana
hop là je pense qu'on en sécurité pour
le moment n'oublie pas ce que tu as
appris aujourd'hui au quai maîtresse
pardon ok maintenant qu'on a battu des
bandits je suis en train de la ramener à
mon qg qui est un bar gaming [ __ ] sera
vraiment le japon va existe tellement
bien
oh la la la la bienvenue au freedom
fighters bays maugras tes habits à tort
ça fait trois jours qu'on t'a pas vu et
calmez vous je sais que j'ai manqué mais
ferme et la [ __ ] j'ai mis à poil des
gens sur la voie publique alors je
devrais être en prison alors qu'il est
bon les amis après de longues
discussions avec tous ces gens en gros
c'est mon qg s'est montée à terre je
peux partir en mission avec la personne
de mon choix par exemple itunes tôt avec
cailleteau avec cathy who avec shizuku
celle pour qui on a un faible
puisqu'elle a un parapluie et
franchement ça montre qu'elle est
prévoyante et qu'elle peut faire face à
des situations imprévues comme quand il
pleut bague au doigt les nouvelles
missions soit qu'on va aller botter le
cul de méchant encore aux mondiaux ça
sur la question vous ferrez hausse et un
taux chaud ok si tu veux continuer à
vaincre dessin sisters tu vas devoir est
plus efficace pour les défoncer juste
après avoir arraché un revêtement
quelqu'un tu peux appuyer sur une touche
pour agen autres vêtements quoi trou
colle aux plats mais en commun cherchait
pas comment jeudi on les a mis tous à
poil en genre cinq secondes real est ok
savoir si j'ai relancé direct mais je
pense que là les mecs vont être beaucoup
plus fort oh [ __ ] merde je me bats
contre un maigre à fort là ok ouvrage
très nerveux au plein à l'aller font pas
je laisse de temps faut laisser aucun
répit poker fut le symbole je peux pas
lui faire le coup mauges arrache tout
mais il est torse nu déjà là il est pas
bien déjà en vrai au le pantalon aaa
il est mort auj on a battu le lightning
au c'est qui lui jai ho oh là là où il
ya les agressifs lui avec sa poubelle à
meyreuil ses torts mais alors c'est un
mec il attaque les couilles
ok en fait il est lent mais il fait
graver mal je veux vraiment les retirer
son avec comme elle me fait mal
il a retiré son jeu le ciel sont bas on
n'a pas plus pu teint hâlé range ta
poubelle mon pote avait pu lui arracher
le bandana là le vexer transcendante
feuilles quoi fonder une seconde allait
plus de mandat n'a on en parle plus on
est chiant la [ __ ] ils sont deux oh oh
oh quel os se dégage
ah non il est trop belle je vais partir
en courant mais je suis faible pouvoir
me déshabiller arrêtez s'il vous plaît
il ya un fou qui me suit avec une route
vous dis aux tripes esquive et je viens
points de tyreke tonga alors là j'ai
fait un bond de génie mon gars ah merde
là par contre je me sens pleinement à
vos pâtes à l'eau potable ou non ses
cauchemars je faisais quand j'étais
petit tu y arrives pour de vrai non non
ils m'ont mis à poil
je suis hyper triste bon succès des
missions dans tous les cas on a fait le
premier groupe de 3 mai cause a défoncé
aucun nouvelle mission apparemment rien
mais qui fait chier les gens à la jump
street alors on va y aller ok les mecs
dans un brouillard vient d'arriver nous
embrouille ses dessins sisters je peux
le sentir
j'ai bien peur de pas avoir d'autre
choix que de les défoncer ok c'est parti
mais je vais me venger de la défaite je
vais faire le combo ils vont se
retrouver à paulhan de seconde pour la
la la la mecque royal à cet enchaînement
causes justes en chêne casque de moto
pas fui ou palm en bas les couilles
vous êtes tous égaux devant la loi et
devant moi aussi et on enchaîne sur un
des lots on n'en parle plus de ce casse
plus tard et toi aussi la techologie en
profite et toi aussi la télé j'en
profite
mais quand on est un couple c'est
n'importe quoi ça fait tellement rire la
vitesse à laquelle ils arrachent les
revêtements en fait je sais du
harcèlement sexuel dit alors elle veut
quoi il lui reste qu elle en fait elle
est due à un poil à noëlla sous faulx up
la normale plus âgés pas réussi à faire
le combo spéciale qui retient les se
fait fort on est déçu bon on dirait bien
qu'on les a tous eu je n'avais jamais vu
autant de pénis en une fois est bien les
amis c'est dans ce doux quartier
d'akihabara autrement appelée lecture et
40 qu'on se quitte je sais pas quand je
les ai sortis mais en tout cas pour être
allé au japon trois fois je peux vous
dire que c'est exactement comme ça et
camara c'est assez impressionnant il ya
même ce mec qui dort ici c'est faux
allez n'hésitez pas à mêler de ça vous a
plu
n'hésitez pas et franchement le jeu et
des graphes cool en vrai c'est il ya
aussi des équipements et tout beau là on
n'a pas beaucoup avancé ces 1 au début
du jeu mais tu peux mettre des vêtements
qui ont plus de résistance qui sont plus
stylé
quel jeu est vraiment pousser quoi c'est
pas juste un jeu indé de merde c'est
vraiment un vrai joue trop cool iceberg
si vous appuyez je vous dis à très dans
une prochaine vidéo portez vous bien et
attention petit tour de magie le tarage
ton pull wop là c'était
[Musique]
ça